мо засідання конкурсної комісії з
проведення конкурсу на заміщення посади
директора державного музею іграшки є наш
наказ Міністерства освіти від 20 березня
17 року Про затвердження склад
конкурсної комісії за по застоупник
міста я лет Наталія Ярославівна директор
Департаменту кадро забезпечення є яромис
Максим Миколайович директор Департаменту
правого забезпечення є міхно Олександр
Петрович є директор чного музею еревська
наталіія Володимирівна є директор
державного політехнічного музею
тименко Володимир Петрович ще не
сказадівсна проспілки так Колесник
Вікторія левантівна є є директор
електронольного музею Максима рильсько
по витіш в
голесієві є Назарко Людмила Іванівна
член все Української громадської
організації і А звікому так скірда
Марина юрївна
це ви заступник Генерального директора з
науковосінського національного музею
містец українськох центру музейної
справи і кабаченко Марина Олександрівна
це я це ви головний спеціаліст віділ
кадро забезпечення секретар комісії яка
Отже Дякую вам колеги Що ви всі прийшли
у нас
стовідсотково присутні членів комісії ее
підготували наші кадроки порядок денний
і відповідно до цього порядку денного
перше питання щодо обрання голови
конкурсної комісії з проведення конкурсу
на заміщення посади директора державного
музею іграшки які будуть пропозиції
щодо обрання
голови кого
миремо
маси А ви можете
бу каж що мій кабінет чи я
голова пропозицію щоб обрати хозея Павла
Павла хозея точніше головою конкурсної
комісії
разд 3 4 5 6 за
Так хто проти Хто утримався
вирима все більшостю голосів обрано
головою зе
Павла наступне
питання ми отрима А може я вам надам
слово нашому фотографю
прошуталі
Ярославівна надійшов
до Міністерства надійшов один пакет до а
секретаря не треба
обирати надійшов один пакет документів
від кобас Юлії
Олександрівни от пакет був повним з
геграфічни довідки біографії з е
мотиваційним листом і двома
рекомендаційними листами це від
державного музею іграшки і між відомцю
художньої-технічної Ради з іграшок та
навчальня наочних ігрових посібників е
ковас Юлія Олександрівна зараз
розглянемо документи у Вас всі вони є
роздані громадянка
України
Має загальний стаж роботи 23 роки і з
2005 року працює методистом вищої
категорії державного музею
іграшки о біографічна
дойкатобіографія
ну відповідає скажть будь ласка тут
Основне питання чи відповідає критеріям
щоби посісти дану посаду ісля завершення
надходження документів її документи були
офіційно виішені на сайті всі могли з
ними ознайомитися жодних зауважень
рекомендацій не надходи не надхо нічого
надходи добре
дякую прошу
ознайомитись
простіше чи члені
кодована тдовим
колективом якісь зауваження члени
комісії хтось хоче
сказати з приводу
документів як немає чудоло підписано Я
дивлюся Олександр
підписала
Ну якщо дозволите немає поки що ніяких
застережень бо я просто не мала з моги
зми ознайомитись що
стосується Це скоріше стосується взагалі
процедурних питань розпочнемо з першого
нас кандидата А вас Шановний пане голове
насправді якщо я правильно розумію оцей
закон і моливості процедури то і уже
були від громадськості зауваження щодо
інших конкурсів які відбувалися там по
лінії особливо
Київради головного управління
культури коли йдеться про трьох
представників засновника не малося на
увазі що це мають бути буквально
керівництво Міністерства освіти в даному
разі Да а малося на увазі що це ті
експерти яким Міністерство освіти
довіряє цій галузі тому я утрималась
от Бо виходить що зараз голова комісії
це водночас
безпосередній керівник да відповідно
наскільки
це наскільки це можна вважати дійсно
відкритим і незалежним незаангажованим
конкурсм це чисто за процедурою другий
момент теж мене дещо бентежить коли
йдеться про конкурс Але знову ж таки це
відбувалося уже і в попередніх конкурсах
і громадськість звертала увагу на те що
це дивна річ якщо не порушення але ну
щодо закону це не порушення але якщо
ійдеться про конкурс то Всі розуміють Да
що якщо конкурс то має бути конкурс
якісь змагання конкуренції от далі
документи це все прекрасно але наскільки
я розумію я як громадський активіст який
долучився взагалі до створення законно і
розробки його на перших етапах Я розумію
що має бути не конкурс
біографії ваційних листів А конкурс
програм і тому от зараз я думаю у нас
буде пауза для того щоб дослідити власне
це питання що це за програма і дійсно чи
дійсно вона є такою
програмоюмене менеджерсь запитання до
вас як до розробника закону а там єсть
якесь положення яке суперечить тому що
може бути обраний наприклад ні такого
положе колеги я хочеш роіть полоння
такого немає да Тобто це все питання
дискутийні так звані через те що закон
він власне ці зміни до закону до деяких
законів да вони щойно увійшли в силу і
ми бачимо що на практиці застосування
закону дуже далеке от як на мене від
того що малося на увазі в ідеалі на
початку коли ми його розробляли навчаємо
шиповідно це що щодо процедурних питань
Я більше якщо дозволите не буду до цього
повертатися просто якісь загальні
засадничі речі щоб ви розуміли а
наприклад чому я утримуюсь під час
голосування бо мене дивляться так
запитаннями Да От я пояснила свою
позицію більше не буду відволікати
уваска пропозиція в нас не може бути в
конкурсній комісії якщо з самого початку
єсть якісь застереження і єде досвід
проведення цих конкурсів ее це ж у нас
згідно закону Ви повинні це відео
виставляти Я так розумію на на загальні
Тобто ми ставимо наперед під сумнів хай
вона не мотивована але під сумнів всю
діяльність комісї в мене є сі пропозиція
Давайте тоді
визначимонодмиж не є безпосередньо
керівником він є особ яка призначає він
є заступником міністра він є засту
мініст вичає
Жан є повноваження визначені але це
мої ви
зрозумілика я не буду наполягати на тому
щоб голову переобирали це буде
неправильно бо насправді ви всіх трьох є
співробітниками і керівниками
Міністерства освіти Я розумію але якщо
ви наперед ставите під сумнів діяльність
комісії то ми не можемо дальше
продовжувати в такому режимі роботи в
мене є пропозиція тоді для того щоб
громадськість не звинувачувала в першу
чергу наше чуєте мене то ви три учасника
комісії уже не зовсім таі з такої точки
зору Вите легітимні члени цієї комісії
Тому вже Далі ви вже учасники цієї
комісії а далі вже хто голова
це ну але зараз стоїть питання про
голову комісії про прошленів тако ж Влас
Марина Юрівна це є коли є одна
кандидатура
це конкурс
перетворитьсяні профонаціпев
профонаціформальніфнаці мож люди
розуміють чому не
йдуть тому ми ж не можемо Чому ви не
забезпечили альтернативу як громадської
організації
чому Не подали Чому ви не подали
альтернативну ви знали що є конкурс Чому
ви не постарались щоб була
альтернативний А ну я наприкла так можу
постави в даному питанні якщо немає але
це все воно риторичне тому що є терміни
є певний закон тому в тому
розумінні ми в якійсь мірі ми як
Міністерство не маємо претенціії до
роботи і тому воно вже існо автоматично
це все я про з вами в цій ситуації бо є
така ситуація але якщо би ви як
громадський сподали алтернативу тоді
може би інакше ми розглядали конкурс на
всі інші речі а зараз Справа в тому що
ми звертались до громадськості для того
щоб громадські організації подавали свою
кандидатури дві громадські організації
подало шість кандидатур було проведене
онлайн жербкування тость Я не бачу
конкусні комісії Я маю на увазі
[музика]
кандидатуруромі я розумію так дочому але
громадськість і громадські організації
вже знали що є така посада да і що буде
оголошено конкурс є серйозна проблема з
кадровим резервом взагалі на будь-яку
посаду директора музеїв в Києві і в
Україні тим більше менеджерів практично
немає от тому всі конкурси не лише на
директора державного музеї іграшки вони
відбуваються не зовсім так як хотілося
ну Але повторюю Все я давайте теоретично
завершимо ча добре Є пропозиція чтані
конкурсної комісії прийняти позицію пані
сди до відома От і продовжити роботу Так
приймається так щодо програми програ
розвиткупоную оскільки законо визначено
два засідання і на другому засіданні
розглядаються ці програми тому я
пропоную зробити спочатку провести перше
засідання зробити перерву і потім
зробити друге засідання перерву Я маю на
увазі для ознайомлення з програмою для
ознайомлення з програмою Тому зараз є
пропозиції зробити перед правильно я
розумію ну спочатку давайте Приймемо
рішення щодо того чи документи
відповідають доку Ну я так зрозумів
відповідають треба голосувати тобто
треба голосувати по процедурі да чи
приймаємо ми документи Да і ставте на
голосування ставимо на голосування про
прийом документів тому що з моїї точки
зору не відповідає Ну о позиці ків Хто
за те щоб прийняти документи пані е
кобас Юлія Олександрівна до
розгляду
Одноголосно Добре
тепер Максим перерви наром перерви
так скільки перерв ми
робимо скільки у нас програм на сторіно
покажіть програму надає кандидат
програму надає кандидат Я за зараз поки
документи на першому засіданні
розглядається докумен нам перерва
потрібна щоб розглянути програму
документи роля нам перерва потрібна між
засіданням у першим засіданням і другим
зас на другому засіданні дру зас а
вказано скільки перерва хоть дві хвилин
ну от так ми й зробили ну оскільки я
оголосили перерви Перепрошую я брала
участь у інших конкурсах да то власне
перерви оголошували саме для того щоб
було тільки дійсно два засідання але під
час перерви була нагода час ознайомитися
з програмою так давайте давайте знаймися
з програмою от а програму треба
прочитати давай прочитаємо кожний і
висловить свої тоді що закриваємо перше
засідання і за нас тоді будуть
мотивовані запитання щодо програми та як
то ми ж Можемо і тут ознайомитися
правильно То де Хоче може все тоді
що ми ми закриваємо програма коро все
добре Дякуємо Коли ми збираємося скільки
часуки це залежить від того скільки
сторінок програ пть ять Ну значить нам
достат ки 10 хвилин Да да 10
хвилин Добре давайте через 10 хвилин
Зараз 25 за
10 Ну я нічого нека мо може критикувати
воно
негарно але
воно трудно назвати тут основні проблеми
які є при скільки ви працюєте в музеї я
так зрозумів що Давно да само почат Ну
на вашу думку які основні проле
основна проблема - це приміщення музе це
вони не дає нам можливість реалізувати
дуже багато чого діяльність Зрозуміло Ви
ви ніби ви наймаєте так ви фінансуєтеся
з Київської адміністрації Ну добре Це
добре джерело велике джерело багато
джерело більше ніж державний бюджет це
це добре бути там Ось але в одно час ви
знаходитеся ніби арендуєте так а місто
Київ не може вам вам надати
приміщення скажи
сь якісь інші приміщення що ви могли
зробити висвку більше тому що у вас
багато і колеги розказують А мало плоч
хоча колега говорить що ви
використовуєте інші музеї щоб виставляти
але знаєте музеї ну які там відсоток
якісь постійні експозиції повинні бути в
музеї я
таммаслухайте у нас по всіх музеях
навіть провідних норма А 2% всі
потерпають від браку площ Ну так бо люди
наприклад по дарували свої картини
сучасному сец промові якщо воно буде
висіти не зас ні висіти хоча фонди
влізли А ви навіть фонди не берете так
нічого собі Я думаю нема грошей на
закупи А ви просто зовсім іншу причину
от то висло живете ну доводиться ну в
національному художньому зараз
перекритий зал який був ставковий і
лекційний через те що там тепер
зберігається частина колекції
хо тому що художній музей - це єдиний
музей який будувався як
музей При тому що будувалися як музей
всі інші адаптуються ідеальні умови там
кондиціонування але все одно є проблема
То наприклад постать кондиціонери а
назад Може на Добре давайте ми зараз не
будемо розглядати проблеми
музею розуміте бо це про не відображено
я оце читаю програму які є Плани Бо
плани складається є якась візія от Яка
ваша візія от помрійте помрійте от який
ви би Бачили там через 5-10 в нас
комунізм все в нас
є От от як от Як ви бачили от ідеально
цього музею роль в суспільстві в
нас Рокі бо я бо я тут не бо тут є
заходи тут просто ваш план дій тобто Не
музей а на короткий середньостроково Що
я маю зробити але це це не є програма Ну
якщо ми мріємо ми мріємо про окреме
приміщення де ми можемо не просто
зробити гарні виставкові зручні зали бо
в нас дуже маленький коридор пере
обладнаний під зал і ми не можемо
приймати більше ніж 45 осіб одночасно У
нас дуже
великі кількості екскурсій дитячих
екскурсій 70 70% - це діти приїжджають
кожного дня в нас екскурсії це переважно
місто Київ ні ні Ну переважно місто Київ
але який відсоток Києва і не не киян Ну
не ч мабуть Може я там за приблизно ви
не робите статистику ви не окуєте може
цю статистику я конкретно цю Не знаю
може робилося але конкретно цю Не знаю
але діти з інших міст ї переважно в
канікули коли канікули ну от зараз у нас
їдуть інші
міста Київ Не їде Їде Київ тільки ви
безкоштовні чи
нініні вхідний квиток є 10 грн тячий
квиток 50 г грнь екскурсія для дітей з
групи до 15 осіб і в нас дуже широка
пігова категорія це безкоштовані
квитки дуже широка і ми а ваші от
відпоже квитки ви який відсоток
покриваєте
своїх Я вам зараз чесно не можу зразу
відповісти спеціального фонду який
відсоток покривається А ти спеціальний
фонд Да да да це спеціальний фонт я ми
мріємо про іграте бо це нонсенс коли де
Музей іграшки коли діти приходять
подивитися дізнатися історію і не можуть
по це да торкнутися ми говоримо Що це
експонати ви до картин не можете
торкатися до до витрів мистецтва Але
вони потребують це потримати в руках
тому в нас є такі під час екскурсій
є ми демонструємо іграшки даємо
погратися дітям вони радіють звичайні з
добре скажіть це це все Ну скажіть мені
От як коли ви бачили ли от вам прийшли
дядько приїхав зідкиляєся в якийсь
український Олігарх і каже я вам дам
Скільки ви скажете тільки скажіть мені
От що ви хочете зробити бо це мої гроші
Я можу дати тільки тоді коли я бачу що
це вони не будуть закопані в землю а
ономтасі от що би ви як би ви бачили цей
музей ну це простори музей це ігротет це
робота з з колекціонерами дуже багато
людей хто займається колекціованням саме
іграшок і цікавиться робота з педагогами
бо ми не розглядаємо іграшка окремо від
гри ігрової діяльності ви Які у вас
працюють Чи ті які назовні які зовні
зовні зовні ми бачимо себе в роботі з зі
студентами Які в нас зараз проходять
практику може більше могли дати їм в нас
є гарна бібліотека яки студенті у вас
проходять практику на проходть практику
яких закладів це інститут культу
університет культури це музейки да потім
університет архітектури Які
спеціальності у там музейники в нас
проходять Ну все Що все спеціальності
пов'язані з музейною
справою
проходять студенти в лабрії які
навчаються там в ВУЗі
це кваліфікації з бойчуками так
співробітнича Драгоманова
Драгоманова нальй
транспорнийресик
дмитрченко да а щоче а там у нього єсть
дизайнери промисловні а в них іграшок
повни тобто як якщо є якась можливість
зацікавленість Ми дамо
СП але ми таки семінар ходили там по
якому це розстп
музей особист дозбо Да звійсно На чому
де вили якщоми брали участь в якихсь
семінарах навчаннях
е останнім часом просто я вийшла на
роботу три місяці тому назад після
декретної впуски це було все до
декретної відпустки музеї коненку
проводилися семінари американці
проводили з популяризації музейних
фондів ее в музей Івана Гончара були на
різно ну різноманітних заходах
пов'язаних з народною іграшкою е були
в заразти в художньому музеї були а щось
спеціальноне з музейного менеджменту
траплялися курсів тренінга ви розумієте
Да ми всі я це в нас є така проблема це
проблема бо ми педагоги ми тільки ну
тільки починає просто в продовж
запитання Що та
вас ми відвідуємо в нас є науковці і які
відвідують молоді люди в в нашому музеї
співробітники які відвідують ці семінари
вони весь час ознайомлюються на багато і
власне ми відкриті до цього я знаю що в
нас є така Ну прогалина та що ми не
музейники з самого початку музейники
не починавк музейщики цеку програму це
запитання про те що очевидно що ви Ну як
менеджер
не готови нутися тре є такі ну якісь
форми якісь кліше от власне подальше що
таке програма от запитують місія візія
От такі слова вони не про те що місія
якась там Патетична А це конкретні
механізми розробки програми яка включає
це бачення потім далі кінцевий результат
який ми плануємо і стратегія - це кроки
Як досягнути з точки А в точку б за 5
років і тому і там розраховуються певним
чином ресурси не так що ми будемо сидіти
і чекати коли нам хтось їх подарує з
іншого боку таке бачення воно е і
потребує відповідальності Бо знаєте
прийде чи не прийде багатий меценат - це
одна історія але всі музеї існують уже
на гроші платників податків і тому
навіть той ресурс який є
використовувати відповідально да І от
власне тому мене цікавило ваше бачення
музею з точки зору громади да от ваш
музей Як ви бачите його його місце для
спільноти для ввас запитання для Києва
для України Ну ще ми цікаві ще й
виробниками грашо бо на базі музею
працює між відомчох технічна Рада яка ви
з Китаєм пов'язані
ні от ви вважаєте що це важливо ви
вважаєте що це важливо бо на Сьогодні
має виробництво іграш Україні не існує А
навіщо виробництво іграшок
покращувати ну В нас є певні знання да
для виробників іграшок в майбутньому
також чому це важливо для суспільства ви
вважаєте Ну бо іграшка являється не
тільки там предметом для гри вона і
ідеологічно впливає
на от ви зараз виходите от зараз ви
виходите на формування отої місії Навіщо
цей музей поті і коли ви виходите з
такою місією що без нашого музея іграшки
не буде ні дітей ні тих хто заробляє
гроші на іграшках будуть китайські там
якісь Да Сурогати і в і і і і далі от
без і далі ви бачите як всі кажуть так
точно фонд Порошенка біжить вам гроші
здавати бо Як же це ж наше все Да От
тому від грамотного формування
формулювання оції мі місі візії не
можливо рухатись далі от це про менеш
але з іншого боку Мені здається що виста
тільки
часу в цьому музеї і в колективі і з
цією колекцією що я думаю щоце ви
вчитись ну молода перевага можна вчитись
І мені здається важливим дуже для
керівника Ну мені здається не знаю з
підручників поменше що
80% роботи це комунікація Угу і мені
чомусь так стається Я вже почитала
послухала колегу подивилася на вас що ви
здатні
полас там де ви чогось не знаєте ви
очевидно зможете знайти того хто знає
хто підкаже і згуртувати людей я
правильно відчуваю Ну я намагаюся Дякую
вам будь ласка а на вашу думку чому
більше ніхто не подав я Я не кажу з
вашого закладу а наприклад з іншого чи
там тці проблеми бояться
чи у нас як на якісь посадуми ректора ну
буваєть ж
тільки Але переважно є багато бажаю то
ректор
скажть заробітна плата директо я
заробітна плата ну методист в мене
виходить на місяць майже 4000
грн а у директора ну трохи більше але
обов'яз
набагато більше А
ну премії ви ж розумієте премії ми
отримуємо з того що заробили А це
маленький
відсо тільки може бути спецфонду такдже
не тільки спецфонду що заробили те й
отримали Ну і велика кількість проблем
окрім
заб якщо Національ то Ну на по
національному
університеті Ні ми в національному
університеті ми
демо Я добре які будуть питання колеги
от У мене є питання 2008 року до
постанови створений музей так от
попереднє керівництво колектива от було
бачення от в місті Києва де б ви хотіли
знаходитися і чи куди ви ходили просили
приміщення які були кроки щоб отримати
це
приміщення ну ну в нас таке по-перше
головна умова - це має бути десь центр
міста Да Де може розташовуватися й не
хочеться переїждти Ну ви знаєте на
клопському я не скажу що це дуже
зручно немає місця де припаркуватися
автобусам які привозять дітей немає
парковки треба дійти до метро з одного в
один в інший бік тобто так не дуже
зручно В нас І в нас окна виходять всі
на сіри сіру будівлю заводу Арсенал
Тобто Ну зовсім зовсім зовсім ми
розглядали Тетяна Олександрівна головний
зберіяч фонді гадала шоколадний
будиночок ми мріяли про за ЦВК є кругла
башта вона там в аварійному стані але це
було дуже гарне місце для музею великі
зали в приміщення для працівників потім
там ігротека обласний двір Тобто там
можна можна було більше зробити але але
але дізналися що воно вже в приватних
руках і комусь це все належить то ви
тільки центр хочете ну ну друзі мо В
цент я чому питаю тому що можна
наприклад в світовій практиці є музеї де
починають Ну наприклад біля метро і там
коли є нове приміщення можна по-перше
вре приміщення От хто великі мають музеї
це проблема буде з фондосховищем
вентиляцію коли у васде нове приміщення
ви можете
вибрати
освітлення правильне О ну тобто ви Якщо
вам виділять в районі метро і Повірте
коли є метро привідуйте ми вже не проти
плюс ще другий момент все ж таки ну
центр міста насичений перенасичений А є
цілі такі масиви спільнота де є бажання
лівий берег ркі лони біля метро така
локація
і а ки при з приміщення не вирішено Я
думаю що люмила Валентинівна все робила
для того щоб десь знайти приміщення може
це буде яко Добре дякую колеги я Ну у
нас ситуація така
людина хоче має мотивацію може іншій
кандидатурів
нема немає в силу ну тух обставин що
досить складна ізне ситуація з са те що
є Я знаю чи є ще питання чи може
ні ось я хочу добавити Ось
що зауваження слушне що треба десь
менеджменту вчитися Але я вважаю що цю
справу в свої руки може взяти
Міністерство освіти бо дійсно вчитися Не
директорам музеїв нема де епізодичне в
нас є навчання якщо когось запитають за
запрошують з закордону Ну і все А
місвіти немає досвіду музейних помоз є
Ну є ж організація яка чо Музейний
портал є можна Тобто це я кажу про
системну осві
систематично про системну освіту бо
питань дуже багато і правових питань і
правових думаю тільки що це питання до
Міністерства і до міні Я взагалі вважаю
що це не питання до Міністерства Що т і
хто хоче той проводить Ну хто хоче Ну є
чому ж є єж які проводить і робить її
проекти відповідно які на не знаю Я
наприклад думаю
що найближчими роками власне я буду саме
віддавати свою енергію тому щоб
створювати От таку структуру для освіти
музейно освіти але це не буде пов'язано
ні з міністерством освіти ні з
Міністерство а з громадською організацію
яка може бачить перспективу може знайти
людей яких можна розвивати далі
бачите 20 років нічого системного нема
більше ніж 20
років навчатися треба всі найближчим
часом думаю от зараз мені здається що
всі конкурси які відбуваються не лише
цей вони носять такий експериментальний
характер вони показують нам де у нас є
слабкі місця і одне з найслабкіших місць
на мою думку це відсутність кадрового
потенціалу тих менеджерів музейників які
могли б очовати музей і відповідно У нас
є Тепер ресурс пть років бо всі вже
конкурси відбулися там призначення ну
здебільшого відбулися да І от за ці пть
років є шанс підготувати зміну дійсно
тих людей які вже будуть
ну створювати дійсно
конкуренцію тому на ближні пть років Я
думаю що треба передати справи в надійні
руки і просто триматися ці Шановні
колеги який проект реалізується зараз
цим музеєм е ми співробітничаємо як
представники педагогічної науки Да і і
шкіл і інститутів університетів оц
синтез наук синтез педагогіки і культури
оце у нас єдиний осередок поки що який є
завдяки тому що вони існують і їхні
художньо-технічна рада існує Нам вдалося
їхні експонати популяризувати в підручни
ка вже початкової школи з гремон освіти
вони всі розповсюджені з їхніми
іграшками називається ігродизайн напрям
ігровий дизайн і от скажемо так у нас
дуже великий проект на них ми
сподіваємося і ми будемо іціювати чого я
і підтримує їх тому що ці іграшки - це
декоративновжиткове мистецтво іграшка як
джерело розвитку українського
ігродизайну українського національного
ігродизайну І взагалі дизай
регіонального дизайну розумієте ми про
це говорили з нею тобто оцей проект
педагогічний завдяки тому що тут вже
Олександр Яківна і всі заступники
міністра знають і він входить в цю
структуру Я думаю нам удасться
приреалізувати во вона не дуже реакційна
вона Передова вона сучасна і оце я
сподіваю про це треба говорити Да От
Влас про це ми ж говоримо чудово що ви
говорите ну значить да то власне Да тоді
ми бачимо перспективу що не треба
боротися
за майданчик в місті в середмісті і тим
більше що навіть якщо буде такий
майданчик це нереально то грошей на
будівництво зараз ну Перепрошую Треба ж
реально дивитися У нас війна в країні
але з іншого але з іншого боку ці п'ять
років витратити на те щоб підняти ще на
щабель Імідж розкрутити його зробити
отакий спільний мультиякісь культурна
культурно-технічно-науковий проект вийти
Можливо там у них є якийсь майданчик
виділять кімнату то ще одне приміщення
да хоча б тимчасово І от на це да І далі
вже через пть років дивишся так всі не
просто ви кажете у вас багато
відвідувачів на рік і це класно а тут
уже весь Київ знає і вже Вся Україна
знає що є такий музей що туди треба і
взагалі створюється Щось таке не просто
там уже школа не просто дизайніграшки а
школа дизайну уже рівня бау хаосу і вже
весь світ каже Да ви що в Києві треба
обов'язково розумієте Якщо от такі от
речі дуже правильно зараз де може бути
переміщення от ми мімо протоксвіти
переняємо ну правда вже в два рази
скоротуликиєвроздавав і так далі може
там щось є може немає але тут може бути
тому що нови гроші не дадуть бо школи
треба будувати садки чко особливо
райох будували будинки
інфраструктури тому дві школи не
будуютьщо 11 садків хоч очевидно що того
бюджету не значить що знувати там музей
красивонувати
е добре В мене є
пропозиція припинити обговорення
проблеми багато не вирішино Мене
цікавить як оця наша реформа нова
українська школа яку мож ці
компетентності
дітей ця діяльність це ж і творення
тотото теж мені здається є дуже велике
поле для
співпраці з освіто навіть з о ч шко діти
я
ющо
зробитиже бажає майбутньому добре які
там процедурні питання зараз Ми дякуємо
і Залишаємо так
дякує
дякуюлучитися людина непогана наскільки
вона готова захоче вчитися буде т
поможете і будето мені здається що
готова в тому сенсі що утримати музей на
пть років і не дада йому розпастися і
підготовити якусь надійну базу стабільну
для майбутнього росвіту за 5пть років за
наступного вже директора це цілком
реально ну тобто зараз мені здається
проміжкове завдання утримати не
розвалити те що є здається кандидатураде
цілком підходить решю рогічний вчинок Як
на мене малеї дитини вятице комплекс
проблем ті хто знає чому що таке
організації відвідуваня чипер не звіти
здають Міністерство освіти чинас там по
в8к цеж це теж серйозна робота
організаційно це на плечі керівника які
будуть пропозиції Шановні колеги
підтримати рішення колективу який її
зобов'язав це робити навіть в такому
стані мабуть принаймні п років шанс
працювати роз добре інші є пропозиції
немає Хто за Цю пропозицію
голосвати все тодіклю у нас пропозиція
це що
рекомендувати затвердити
Да бо затверджеує засново Да ми тільки
скажемо
то ви зас ви
засно наскільки я
розуміюп років з укладанням
контракту достроко да все Хто за то
випишуть семінар Више правильно юридично
тому за цей ж Прос з ну є пропозиція
закупити всім
подякую вам дякую за уватейст
Одноголосно
комісія православа рекомендую призначити
що контракт заключає держав секретар з
вами не ми бажаємо вам успіху Дякуємо що
ви згодилися хоч один кандидат Щоб ми
робили якби нікого не ось було би тяжко
і втримайте музей і думайте про розвиток
Великого бажайте я казав
си Великого
бажайте все
дякуюватезвоте
мку добре комісія Дякую за участь за
небайдужість те що є і тоді